ring doorbell video catches a suspect in  the act after pointing a gun at a couple  who he followed home it happened on july  15 about 20 minutes west of denver  colorado a couple there says they were  walking home when a man and woman  started following them after that the  suspects followed the couple home where  the male suspect pointed a gun at their  faces that's when the couple ran inside  and slammed the door  investigators say minutes after the  suspect sped off they robbed another  person at gunpoint anyone with more  information about the suspects are asked  to contact the wheat ridge police  department stay with long crime network  for the latest developments in the case